how are you Jeff Garlin I'm a big bowl
of I'm actually wonderful considering
what the Cubs did I'm actually wonderful
yeah I don't I don't mean to pry but how
do you feel about it I it was you know
what I got to be honest with you yes
there is no team I hate in baseball more
than the Brewers I've always hated the
Brewers my hardness oh yeah as a matter
of fact in football I hate the Vikings
more than I hate the Packers so the
Bears archenemies per se I verse
respectful I respect for the Cardinals
and I respect for the Packers I have no
respect for the Brewers and none for the
Vikings with their horn sound that they
make every time they do something right
I hate them and I hate the Brewers I
hate the Brewers I met the Brewers owner
a lovely man but he owns the Brewers so
screw him what do you have against the
broom I hate them there should be in the
American League they used to be I know
that's where they still should be and
the fact that the Cubs who dominated
loss play out by the way I was done
prior to the Rockies game I knew they
were gonna lose to the Rockies and my
gut I was like I was like oh we got this
I'm like no no no we don't the thing I'd
be pissed about is that they made you
play a hundred and sixty third game
against a team that you'd already beaten
in the regular season I mean you the
Cubs won the season series against the
broom play take a step back the wild
card game is the dumbest it's it's it's
second only to the all-star game getting
home-field advantage
but how stupid it is I'd look they've
got the three divisions now it's not
Eastern what okay fine
one wild-card team you go in boom you
start the season
the idea of two teams especially when
one of them has the BEC second best
record in the nationally and the other
one is a group of mentally challenged
children who beat them I'm so that's
what I think about these Rockies are
gonna get swept now which they should be
swept and then the Brewers should be
swept by the Dodgers it's done but the
Yankees one of these Yankees are gonna
beat the Red Sox which is disgusting why
because why I know you love
it's about to say I'm really excited
about this I'm all about the Red Sox now
I know you're a Yankees fan
Thank You Jeff Garlin why are you all
about the Red Sox because the Red Sox
are a brother to the Cubs it's the same
kind of background okay why because it
took so long there was everything I love
the Red Sox from George boomer Scott
yeah and I go Petrocelli
to Thompson Butch Johnson no to all of
it all over the years I I love the Red
Sox and I want them to destroy the
Yankees but it's see this is also the
thing that happens that's why the
regular season is such a big bowl of
crap in almost all sports now is because
right now the Yankees are on fire and
the Red Sox are dominated are not on
fire they're not terrible like the Cubs
have been but they're not they're not
they're they're not the Red Sox e self
right now so you think that despite
having a hard way
the Yankees should not have a chance to
be in the playoffs I mean that they all
by the way yes and my way in my world
one or two teams make the playoffs
that's it and then old school old school
I mean the the NL West and East you know
I used to love the Mets Cubs rivalry
this I like that I actually am good with
two teams more than that I get not Jeff
Garlin here on the Rich Eisen show I did
have to explain to my 10 and
seven-year-old boys what the pennant
chase meant they were hearing the
conversation in the game about winning
the pennant and the pennant chase is on
and I explained to them it's a flag it's
a flag you're chasing the flag that you
raised yeah and the look back they gave
me is like what did your you're chasing
a flag like they had it was totally a
bizarre assume their Yankees fans yes
because of daddy because of debt well as
you know my wife my boys are Cub fans as
you know born in LA they my wife got a
lot of New England influenced Celtics
Patriots right that's fine oh she's got
Celtics patron I drew the line at the
Red Sox Yankees
I would have killed you with there as
your wife a Red Sox fan
oh god bless her oh yeah love tell
stories about the locker room as a girl
hanging out and seeing Jim Rice your
wife is beautiful and has great taste in
baseball teams she loves you too as you
know yeah but but the Yankees are gonna
kill the Red Sox I'm sorry it's done by
the way I will take that I don't have
that done
Yankees Dodgers World Series now that's
what I'm that by the way I would enjoy
that World Series that's because I
really do dig the Dodgers 2 Cubs lost
and it's all because of the Brewers
that's all I'm saying
the Brewers hobby out loud look if we
would have lost to the Cardinals
wouldn't be this upset I just that's
just amazing it's like you know the
Brewers the like when the Tampa Bay Rays
won the East really you're going oh well
deserve rice no you're going the race
really and I'm saying Brewers really
Brewers what are you thinking your bears
well since we got Khalil Mac and with
Vic Fangio and the players we have we
are now one of the top defenses it and I
say we cause you know I'm in the front
you're in the monster that you're the
monster of the Midway by the way can I
say for the record yes I have bought for
the 2012 20 19 seasons season tickets
it's not this year right but I have
season tickets 50-yard line
someone's giving up their tickets and I
bought them your three tickets your bag
will be in Soldier Field starting next
season on the 50-yard line except when
it's too cold
right there yeah you're in yeah so you
don't see me I'll sell it you bought it
I bought into the Bears before we got
Kaleo Mac I did this well okay Kaleo Mac
just adds excitement and by the way I
would have thought Mitch strabinsky
would on a good game with like an
impressive game would have thrown two
touchdowns yeah I did it eat at five and
a half
and sex that's just a big bowl of well
by the way it's very exciting
let's see what happens it's very
exciting and I know his receivers must
be so happy
and Tarricone tarik that's a record
territory tarik love them love them
although when the dude gets hit he's
down cone is a difficult guy to hit once
you hit him he goes flying actually
you're receiving its tackle he just
flies and reversed me he's so light but
it's delightful delightful and Jordan
Howard no it's exciting I didn't know
that I'd have this to enjoy but if they
go 500 I'll be shot I don't think
they're gonna go 500 I think I said I'll
be shot their defense to Khalil mca's
isn't as a particular beast you know and
we had your coach on earlier this week
and to use your phrase delightful man I
couldn't have been keeping his head in
the plays well he doesn't want to use
what tool it's being read no no I know
that but this is this is right vid you
don't have a vision of a football coach
like this mm-hm with a thing in front of
their face but by the way five
touchdowns and a half I ain't arguing
whatever he wants to do I don't know
anything except this shirt is light it's
comfortable it's delightful young people
enjoy it and you look great in it as
well I'm a handsome young I know you
love playing start bench cuts bench
this thing in your car and you're
watching at home but you hearing fine
alright okay brought to you by Discover
card young people love the discover they
do I know what you should do with your
Discover yard card
but by a 2019 pilot well if you did that
you'd get all cash back at the end of
your first year is a one-year
anniversary gift at the end of your
first year discovers gonna match all the
cash back you've earned dollar for
dollar no caps no catches tried and
believe it a discovered calm / match
only four new card members but be
careful Jeff limitations apply
limitations always always apply but I
know what the limitations are doing me
tell you no you cannot I'm gonna tell
you any of with a Discover card they
don't allow you to buy pottery so if you
go to a pottery shop no pottery no
pottery and you can lose all the pay bad
stuff they give you if you even try
buying pot what if you try to rent the
movie Ghost you're all good you sure
there's pottery in it I know but that's
not buying pottery that's going up a
video of some sort so no can't use it at
a pottery barn what about that if you're
using it on pottery it's very specific
rich you know if you've got these people
of sponsors learn they're learning the
limitation thank you all right start
bench cut with Jeff Garlin hit the music
please
first up you're gonna love this one most
insufferable sports fan base okay
Boston New York Philadelphia start one
bench one cut one most insufferable
insufferable one the most inseparable
well get intro for this because of the
Goldbergs which takes place in Philly
but Philly you start in Boston in New
York I would bench Boston and cut New
York so but I like New York sports fans
okay yeah I like that yeah
Boston sports fans Red Sox fan way over
a Yankees fan I there's
their sister city to the Chicago Cubs
and then Wrigleyville some orphans a
sister city okay
okay sister fanbase it's what you're
saying for the Red Sox it's not like
Celtics and bulls are partners all right
next one the most important part of the
85 Superbowl chicken
important part of the 1985 Super Bowl
champion Bears have to start bench cut
Ditka buddy Ryan Mike Singletary okay so
most important most important part of
the 85 and start Mike Singletary okay I
bench buddy Ryan and I cut Mike Ditka
Ditka Zout yeah so you have you ever
interviewed Mike did good oh yes I'm not
the smartest man in the world
everyone loves Ditka so much I love the
feeling of Ditka Ditka thing but I think
they won in spite of him I think you put
another coach just a really great coach
they're gonna win and Buddy Ryan could
have been that coach buddy Ryan was
great so you are you are team but anti
Ditka I'm predict and I loved it but
come on man
but it's nuts it's the vagaries of Stark
bench con it makes you seem anti Ditka
when you're really pro did good but he's
still cut three option I did alright
here's the last one for you okay last
one can we just do like 90 minutes and I
know you love doing this yeah
is it true you live with Conan O'Brien
in Chicago said I did live with Conan
O'Brien avocado yes indeed what was that
near Wrigley Field you and every great
duck Brit but by the way three apartment
no two apartment buildings down with
wave Dylan Kenmore from my back patio I
could see into the the left-field line
no I could see I could see in the home
plate and then from my bedroom it was
the first year of the lights when I
lived there when they put the lights in
and the lights are on it flooded my bed
oh yeah well I couldn't afford them I
was a kid in second city and I was your
cousin was my roommate yeah how is he
amazing hilarious and ironically we used
to do a fake talk-show in our living
room come on swear and his guests were
right he was it was a it was a fake talk
show hosted by George Takei because he
does a great George Takei me from Star
Trek and his guests and the only does he
add were Adam West of which I do and
Jeff Garlin so get what's your atom want
sound like you never heard me I've never
heard you do a seriously so here's how
good it is close your eyes okay it
appears to me that the Joker Riddler and
the cat woman have escaped here's Jeff
Garlin you know okay my voice was
different the movie wall-e judges our
voice okay I screamed so much in the
movie and were three years on it boom
changed my how about that alright so
start bench cut last one I said which
curb character would make the best
roommate
Larry Leon or Susie oh god that's hard
start bench I would I would Wow I would
start Larry David
mmm-hmm I would bench j.b smoove early
at Leon its character yeah and I would
cut Susie oh my god oh yes I would cut
Susie in a second that is by the way yes
people ask me about you know thing is
Susie Essman is a very close friend of
mine I love her but the character of
Susie I find the show not believable I
would have divorced the receivable by
the way my character is not a winner
yeah he's he has no morals no integrity
they're both awful but one causes
constant pain
ICS filming begun coming begins October
19th
so we're days away yes have you seen
Tommy you've seen scripts holdup scene
the whole circuit the arc it's awesome
can you give me a hint it involves my
character okay cause Larry's character
tease and JP's moves character okay yeah
you like it
I love it do you get a sense of this is
it I always do I always think the
seasons the last and most far as I'm
concerned is the last season do you
think so
yeah I think so I always do like for the
past three or four I've always thought
actually no not two seasons ago the one
we took five years in between right I
knew we'd do another season but outside
of that season and maybe the first
couple seasons I've always thought the
current season was gonna be it so last
year when you started principal filming
for last season you thought that would
be it
no I thought we were yes I'll be it and
yet here you are yeah here I saw they're
saying there's a chance
always a chance okay by the way when I
fall in love with women that it's
unrequited the the thing that they do to
me to torture me is they always say this
statement I'll never say never don't
give me hope take away hope when you
take away hope you're doing me a favor
you're doing me a favor saying never say
never look look at where I am in life
I'm a successful man I didn't get this
way from not taking adversity head-on so
don't give me hope that's all I am like
a Cub fan right there don't get me home
don't get me up right and by the way the
Cubs season six of the Goldbergs airing
Wednesday 8:00 p.m. Eastern last night
they're doing well and people love it
and the cups curb can't wait to hear
well you know the exploits that start
filming in just a couple of days by the
way I've never you know Adam B I'm 56
years old never use the word exploits
until just now no you used it
but you just used it and in describing
what I just said that's exactly right so
I just used the word exploits twice now
nice I gotta tell you something yes
nobody loves a good exploit like me so
from now when when people ask me what's
been going on with you I go
lots of exploits big bowl of exploits
big bowl of exploits what did you say
was it good the team name based on what
he said before the scent of scent of
descent of descent of Ditka was there a
team name no I don't like that why don't
you tell the audience we controlling I
can't it's it's an Anatomy that you've
grandma loves Bea Arthur scram is the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience